I'd like to thank the organizers for
workshop every good for these clickers
okay good so just 15 seconds to let you
get used to the sound of my voice I'm
going to be explaining about a new model
we have for interacting with probability
distributions and lets you have some fun
with algorithms and we're looking
specifically at the property testing
algorithms in this new model so I'll
tell you about the model I'll tell you
about some of the property testing
results that we have in this model and
explain some kind of more generic tools
things we can do in this model and if I
have a little bit of time at the end
I'll say just a word or two about some
of the applications of the tools i'll
mention ok so we've heard i think a lot
about this general framework already in
this workshop so i'll keep the basic
setup for property testing of
distributions brief but just to remind
you of sort of the framework of what I'm
talking about everything I'll say in
this talk is about very simple
distributions distributions over finite
set the set of integers 1 through n and
think of an is big and it's a colossal
number so we have some unknown
probability distribution over this
domain and it's a framework where you
have some kind of Oracle access to the
to the distribution the usual model
peeking ahead a little bit is that the
kind of Oracle you can access is a
sampling Oracle what we call just you
you know press a button and you get an
IED draw from the distribution ok so
that's the standard Oracle that's the
standard model but the talk will
actually be but a different model just
to have you know so the basic framework
you have sup you have a distribution you
don't know what it is you can access it
somehow through an Oracle standard model
we just explained there's a property of
interest so some distributions have this
property that you care about some
distributions don't have the property
and what do we want to do we want to
make a small number of calls to the
Oracle as small as possible certainly we
want it to be sub linear and n the size
of the job that the support size of the
distribution and we'd like to be able to
distinguish between two cases the first
case is that the unknown distribution
has the property and the second case is
that the distribution not only doesn't
have the property but it's far from
having the property it's far in some
distance measure form all distributions
with the property so in sort of computer
science speak we would think of this as
like a promise problem
you're sort of promised that the
distribution either has the property or
is far from having the property okay so
the standard setup like I said we would
think of the type of Oracle you have
access to is just independent draws from
the distribution we want to solve our
problem with this few drawers as
possible and the standard setup and the
setup will be talking about throughout
this talk is that the distance measure
how far is this distribution from that
one it's just l1 distance total
variation distance okay so you really
don't need to read this sort of lent the
definition of the testing algorithm
maybe just look at the first line of the
definition i want to emphasize the fact
that a testing algorithm within a
particular sort of oracle framework
right if you have some type of oracle
access to the distribution then you want
to make as few calls as possible to the
Oracle you want to with high probability
say two-thirds say yes if the
distribution has the property and say no
if the distribution is epsilon far from
having the property okay so a familiar
setup from previous talks just a couple
of standard remarks about this kind of
framework again it's a promise problem
so we don't care what happens if your
distribution is close to having the
property but it doesn't quite have the
property think of it as if you never
have to deal with such a distribution
sort of accurate the sort of confidence
of you know you want to be right with
probability two-thirds in each case is
arbitrary you can always boost that in
standard ways you can think about
frameworks where you have several
Oracle's interview of two distributions
and you want to know where these two
distributions the same are they far from
each other so you have one Oracle for
accessing each distribution and again
the kind of thing we're going to be
obsessively concerned with is the sort
of query complexity how many calls do we
have to make to the Oracle we won't
worry about the running time of
algorithm okay so it's a pretty simple
framework let me instantiate it in a
concrete way we'll return to this
example later think of maybe the
simplest property in the world just the
property of uniformity being the uniform
distribution so we can always think of a
property as just a set of objects that
have the property excuse me in this case
the set of objects is extremely simple
it's just the set with one element the
uniform distribution the distance to the
property is just the variation distance
between your distribution d in the
uniform distribution it's the only guy
in the set and how does distribution
testing work in this standard model
where you have a sampling Oracle you
just get ied drawers well kind of all
algorithms work the same way you
press the button a bunch of times get
some draws from the distribution then
you do some computation some analysis of
the samples that you got for instance if
you're testing uniformity the standard
algorithms Greg referred to them
yesterday work by essentially counting
collision seeing how many collisions you
get and if it's too many or too few you
say you think it's uniform or far from
uniform you draw your points you process
them somehow and you output accept or
reject based on the result and all
algorithms in this sort of standard
sampling model have to work this way
because there's nothing else they can do
they get the data they process it and
make a decision so that's the standard
framework just to briefly recap some
results again I think we've heard about
already in this workshop in this kind of
standard model many very simple and very
natural properties of probability
distributions can be tested in a
sublinear number of queries but not in a
really dramatically sibling your number
of queries so most properties you might
be interested in still are going to
require something like square root of n
square root of the domain size number of
queries in order to do this kind of
testing too so some examples here that I
know we've seen already in the workshop
testing uniformity we have very tight
bounds essentially square root of an
over epsilon squared many samples are
required necessary and sufficient
testing equivalents to a known
distribution Greg gave us type bounds on
that yesterday so I should get rid of
this tilde testing equivalence of two
unknown distributions we have we know
that this sort of lay of the land is for
these types of problems and it's always
somewhere in the polynomial regime right
so square root of n is fantastic it's a
lot better than n but if n is really
really colossal it still may be too many
samples right more calls to the Oracle
than you would like to make so that sort
of motivates this work we try to think
about other models other forms of access
you might conceivably have to a
distribution and say see what can you
say about algorithms given these other
forms of access so in this model the the
rest of the talk will be you know
talking about the new model our model is
I guess we call it a conditional
sampling Oracle how does it work so it's
not a framework anywhere where you just
press a button and get a draw from the
distribution instead the algorithm the
calls the Oracle gets to do something
right it gets to specify a subset of the
domain and what does it get back it
doesn't get a drawback from the whole
distribution it gets a drawback from the
distribution conditioned on it landing
in that subset so this is what i mean by
sort of a conditional
sample right you say please give me an
outcome conditioned on this the subset
of the possible outcomes okay and I
don't want to get into a long song and
dance about trying to justify the model
that may be a hopeless task but you can
think of it as you know maybe being a
very rough first approximation to a
scenario where you're doing some kind of
scientific experiment and you can
control in some sense some of the
parameters of the experiment and
restrict the range of outcomes in that
way you introduce a chemical agent into
your peppery dish and kill all the
bacteria which can't tolerate that agent
so what now when you pick a random
bacteria it's drawn from the
embarrassing okay looking uh yeah so
it's a sort of a kind of more precise
definition of the model this cond Oracle
just to get used to the notation you
give it a subset s again just what I
said before and you get back a draw from
the conditional distribution conditioned
on the subset s okay so I think it's a
very simple kind of framework so just to
say a couple of things this is a
generalization of the usual sampling
model the usual sampling model of course
corresponds to just you don't do
conditioning you do trivial condition
they can take the whole thing if you
like playing around with algorithms you
might enjoy this model because it lets
you do more sorts of interesting things
right you're not restricted you're just
hitting the button a bunch of times
doing some analysis of the sample and
you know outputting an answer you can
have adaptive algorithms and indeed you
sort of should have adaptive algorithms
in this kind of framework right you hit
the button a couple of times see where a
few of the points live and now you say
oh based on this I want to condition on
this piece of the domain and see what
see what i get if i sort of zero in on
this this portion of the domain and so
on so one very natural criticism which
you guys were all too nice to make on
the last slide is that it may be wildly
unrealistic to say hey you know what you
is the algorithm calling the oracle get
to give is an arbitrary subset of this
domain right i was just blathering on
about how huge this domain is this
capital n elements set can you really
specify realistically like an arbitrary
subset of this set as a call to the
Oracle that might be too much to
reasonably expect so we study a couple
of variants of the model in which you
can only sort of make these conditional
queries on sets with very simple or
concise structure so one of them is this
piece for pair cond model so you can
make sort of standard sample calls you
know give me an arbitrary point give me
a draw from the whole distribution or
you can say just get here are two points
and I just want to draw a condition none
of being one of the
is two points so I don't think this is
totally crazy maybe you have some kind
of expert and he's not comfortable you
know sort of having a mental model of
the conditional distribution over an
arbitrary bizarre subset but if you
present him with two possible things
which might happen in his domain of
expertise he'll say to you you know I
think this one is five times as likely
as the other one something like that
some kind of comparison essentially type
of thing is what you can do in this
Paracon model this other modest other
variant of the model icon dies for
interval just you get to aquarium
interval so you have to think of the
points 1 through n is you know not being
butterflies or fish or something but
actual ordered values 1 through ran
right and then you can say I want to
zero in on this interval that is the
domain so on and so forth okay similar
models were also studied around the same
time that we started thinking about this
and work of chakrabarti at all they gave
some very nice results which have kind
of a destroyed flavor to what I'll tell
you about okay so the basic question we
have this model right is it worth
studying do algorithms in this model can
they do more can they be more efficient
can make you know solve problems with
fewer queries than the standard sampling
model and the answer is yes in many
cases they can be exponentially more
efficient in fact for all of the
problems that we study there at least
exponentially more efficient than the
standard standard model algorithms so
here's a table which may cause your eyes
to glaze over a little bit it's a it's a
fraction of the actual table in the
paper if you just want to zoom in and
sort of see the qualitative sort of
point to take away from this is that in
the standard model for these different
types of problems right so you've got a
known distribution d star and you have
an unknown distribution d that's the one
your Oracle is for and you want to know
is d the same as d star or far from d
star maybe you've got to unknown
distributions d1 and d2 you want to know
where these the same distribution or far
from each other so for these different
types of problems in the standard model
you always need a polynomial dependence
on n in order to solve these testing
problems and in the conditional sampling
model sometimes you can solve them with
a number of queries completely
independent of n but even in the worst
cases you never need more than a poly
logarithmic number of queries as a
function event so the model gives you
very considerable power potential
efficiency savings
what's the cotton and people yeah good
so cond is a model where you get to ask
and are you is the guy who's invoking
the Oracle get to give it an arbitrary
subset yes that's right picon is you
just get to give it either to point
subset or a draw from the from the
standard sample and icon which I guess
didn't make it onto this table you get
to give it an interval okay okay so in
the rest of the talk I'll sketch the
ideas behind a couple of these specific
algorithms so testing uniformity testing
identity to a known distribution after
that I'll tell you about some kind of
tools I used to think of these tools is
sort of analogous to like the crucial
Levites mansoor algorithm and uniform
distribution learning right it's like a
basic thing you want to do and that
framework is estimated fourier
coefficient right what are some basic
things you might want to be able to do
to a distribution or learn about a
distribution a now we're setting so tell
you about some tools and they have one
slide at the end on sort of how you can
apply the tools okay question yeah just
think of it sir do you mean the set that
the that the tester gives to the there's
like one fixed e that you want to
understand something about and if you're
the testing algorithm may be the first
thing you do is you just draw a random
sample the second thing you do is you
draw another random sample and then you
say oh based on these samples I'm going
to provide this set s and I'm going to
get a conditional sample it's adaptive
yeah yeah in fact most of the
interesting aspects of the algorithms
come from that activity okay so let's
talk about the simplest problem we
touched on this already testing whether
your distribution is uniform or far from
uniform and just remind you again in the
standard model if you just get to draw
ID points from the distribution you need
square root of n over epsilon squared
samples to draw to solve this problem
and just to very briefly sketch the
lower bound really all I should have on
the slider it's the words birthday
paradox right i mean if your
distribution is uniform and you make
rude and over 100 calls you're just
going to see root n over 100 different
points if your distribution is not
uniform but it's uniform over say a
random subset of half the domain then
again right if i chose the subset
randomly sort of behind the scenes
before the process starts and you make
written over 100 random calls you're
going to see again a completely
form random subset of rude and over 100
distinct points so just a quick sketch
that you know you really need something
like Rita and many samples if you just
have ID draws from the distribution
distinguish between uniform and
something far from uniform ok so how do
we get more power in the conch model but
we get a lot more power even just the
pair kondal muddle for a problem like
this in a very simple way so you can
solve this problem with one of our
epsilon squared queries and in fact this
is tight you can show you need 1 over
epsilon squared queries and how do you
do it you can do it in the simplest
possible way just by a couple of basic
observations so suppose your
distribution is far from uniform ok
uniform would be like a flat histogram
this guy's like below somewhere and
above somewhere and so on so what does
that mean if it's far from uniform well
there must be a lot of points which are
quite light which are significantly
lighter than like 1 over N mass right
this is kind of obvious and there must
again it's far from uniform the other
side of lake and you got your valleys
and you've got your hills there must be
a lot of weight on heavy points points
which weigh a lot more than 1 over N it
may only be too heavy points or one
heavy point but they have to have a lot
of weight for it to be far from uniform
ok so this is good because points of the
first type type a there are a lot of
these points that are very light and I
can just pick random elements of the
domain on my own without invoking the
Oracle at all and I'll find such points
ok on the other hand points which are
very heavy under the distribution I can
call the Oracle just the the
honest-to-goodness like sampling Oracle
I can just make IG draws from the
distribution and I'll get some heavy
points so now i have a bag of points
over here in one of these points is
light lighter than one over n i have a
bag of points over here one of these
points is heavy heavier than one over N
and if i can make conditional samples
just on a pair of points i'll try a
point from here in a point from here
I'll query that pair you know a bunch of
times and I'll see if I tend to get this
point a lot more than I get this point
then it means this point was a lot
heavier than this point and it wasn't
uniform ok so if you implement this with
a little bit of care you can get one of
our epsilon squared samples for testing
uniformity and all we're using again are
these parecon queries queries on pairs
of points
boom yeah Olympic refuse what a more
toast oh sure yeah something accorded d
is stemming 10 right sampling according
to DS the standard model the pair model
you get to make samples according to d
and you get to make a conditional query
on a subset of size to write something
beautiful well I can just pick a random
number 13 ran you can't stop me from
doing that some coins and oh that's no
yeah there's no I think yeah there's no
there's no Oracle involved in this step
I'm just sampling these points yeah I
should have said I should like this
first this first line i should have just
written tossing log and coins here yeah
exactly sorry what's your name i see
what I've silent or you count the one
who grabbed stick no so the expensive
step is actually using the pair con to
compare these points call it through
absolutely love with you have to call it
a few times to get reliable estimates
you actually want to do something a
little smarter than checking all one of
our epsilon squared many this point
versus this point that would cost you
something like 1 over epsilon to the
fourth I think so you do it in a smarter
way and you can you get 1 over epsilon
squared yeah even though you're checking
one of your epsilon squared pairs you
can sort of amortize the cost yeah sure
you mention the uniform on a subset of
points um so then have additional be
wasting 14th outs you get support so I
didn't catch the question so here you
say that uniform over and random subset
of a in this this is the lower bound
sketch for the standard model yeah I
mean in general when set this actually
realize distribution is uniform on the
subset yeah so what would be a wise
comparison of two points outside its 3
questions so what would happen in this
setting let's think about that setting
suppose the distribution is uniform on a
random unknown subset of the points what
would happen in the first step I'm going
to choose random I'm going to choose a
bunch of uniform random points and some
of them will not be in the support of my
distribution day and the second step I
make draws from my distribution day so
I've got a point over here which has
wait 0 under the distribution di have a
point over here which has way to over n
under the distribution d when i call my
parrot conned oracle on that pair of
points i call it 10 times and all every
time it gives me this point
I'm calling the Oracle on a pair of
points which has nonzero mass under the
distribution because I call it on one
point that i picked uniformly not using
the oracle just tossing my coins and the
other point is a point that i got from
making samples according to d so it is
it is a well-defined oracle call let's
talk about this afterward i think we're
going to get into a digression yeah okay
alright so just a little bit of how you
extend this to solve a somewhat more
general more interesting problems
suppose you're not trying to test
whether your distribution DS equivalent
to the uniform distribution you're
trying to test whether it's equivalent
to some other known but arbitrary
distribution d star okay so you can't do
a trivial extension and just say well
i'm going to kind of do the same sort of
thing with these pair cond calls right
if you think about the uniformity
testing case right in the uniform case
everything is equal so with like one of
our epsilon calls i can tell whether
these two points are equal right to a
pair of these points versus at this
point is actually 1 plus epsilon times
as heavy as this point okay in the
general distribution case maybe i have
two points that under d star the
distributional trying to test equality
to they have a very skewed ratio of
weights x star is a lot heavier than y
star and now i want to figure out in the
under under my distribution d his ex
star you know root n times as heavy as
as as X is X I want to figure out
whether X is rude n times as heavy as Y
or is it to root n times as heavy as y
well I'm gonna have to call my Oracle
root n times in order to distinguish
these two cases right so you can't do
sort of cheap comparisons the way you
can do cheap comparisons if you're
comparing things that are of equal
magnitude ok so you can't extend the
algorithm trivially you have to be a
little bit careful you look at the
points in the domain and through some
slightly careful decomposition it's
possible to show that you can break it
up into point subset pairs in such a way
that points will be comparable to
subsets right so the ratio of weight on
X to the ratio of weight on this subset
y will be in the sort of constant
parameter regime and then you can invoke
the same kind of idea right that I'll be
able to figure out whether they agree
under this distribution this
distribution by making
essentially a constant number of sample
calls so it seems to be a little bit
more expensive but we can still do this
with a query complexity independent of n
and I should mention it's not a
coincidence that we weren't able to show
that in the perak on you you know we
weren't able to come up with a pair cond
algorithm something as simple as the
uniformity algorithm for this testing d
versus D star problem and that's not a
coincidence there's enough very
difficult construction showing that you
actually need a dependence on an
something like squirt log n many queries
if you're only allowing yourself these
pair cond queries can only compare
points you need a dependence on n if you
get to compare sort of a point versus a
subset then you can do it with query
complexity independent event okay so
I'll just probably have climbed to say a
couple of words about some of the tools
and then I'll close so what are some of
these tools I want to tell you about
well the very first tool something we've
listened discussing already which is
this sort of comparison Oracle right if
you've got two disjoint subsets of the
domain x and y very natural thing you'd
like to know is you know what's sort of
the ratio of weight on X versus on why
and it's obviously easy to estimate this
kind of thing in the regime's where the
ratio is not too skewed if the ratio is
extremely skewed you can either estimate
it or you can say hey it's waste queued
this guy's a lot lighter this guy's a
lot heavier that kind of thing so
comparison is very easy let me move on
and tell you about another tool which is
not quite so easy so you've got your
distribution d this is the guy you have
an Oracle for and you've got some point
decks okay x has a certain amount of
weight which I'm denoting D of X you
might be interested in sort of how
typical is this point X what fraction of
the weight of the distribution is on
points that have about the same amount
of weight as X okay so we're going to
call this the gamma neighborhood of X is
the set of points who have you know up
to some multiplicative 1 plus gamma fact
they're the same amount of probability
mass as X does okay so that's this
notion of the gamma neighborhood of X it
turns out in some settings you'd like to
be able to figure out how much weight
does your distribution d put on the
gamma neighborhood of X so I have a
theorem here in quotation marks which
says that we have an algorithm which can
do this for you you give it a point X in
a parameter gamma and it will give you a
multiplicatively accurate estimation of
the weight of gamma under X this theorem
is in quotation marks and highlighted in
red because it's a damn
why we can't do this no algorithm can do
this and if you're interested you can
think about it for a minute or two why
it's impossible for at least two
different reasons for any algorithm to
action we do this so we can morally do
this okay so it turns out that this is
another used is another tool which is
useful in some contexts while you ponder
this this is horrible I that I've told
you let me move on to the very last tool
and I think the minute or two I have
left this last tool is sort of an
approximate Oracle for evaluation of the
distribution so what would an exact
evaluation our uncle people would be the
simplest thing in the world right you've
got your distribution you've got a point
X sort of exact Oracle for evaluating
the probability mass function of the
distribution would be an Oracle where
you give it the point call it I star and
it gives you back a number between 0 and
1 the amount of mass the distribution
puts on that point it would be great if
you had this but that's crazy right this
is some transcendental number or
something no Oracle is going to tell you
that there's no way to get an exact
value so you say well maybe there's an
approximate eval Oracle you know the
natural definition is that maybe there's
some algorithm where with high
probability it gives me a good
approximation some high accuracy
multiplicative approximation to the
amount of mass that the distribution
puts on some point you think about this
for a minute you see this is all so
ridiculous right how can you conceivably
do this maybe your point DyStar either
has inverse double the exponential rate
or inverse triply exponential wave and
every other point has a lot more weight
than that you're not going to get any
useful information about the amount of
weight that's on I star whether it's in
this regime or whether it's in this
regime without making a preposterous
number of calls so this definition is
hopeless to meet as well but also it's
ridiculous why do you care whether it's
a you know inverse ugly exponential or
embers triply exponential right these
are not parts this is not an amount of
mass that you should really be
interested in for your distribution and
indeed that's what one is ultimately
able to achieve for these sort of the
real definition but approximate eval
Oracle is what it's that you've got some
error set there's some subset of the
domain which has small mass which has
mass less than epsilon and for all the
points which are not met you know small
mass region of the domain you can
efficiently get a high-quality
multiplicative estimate of the amount of
mass that the distribution puts on the
point okay so this is a pretty powerful
thing to be able to do and it turns out
you're able to do this we can simulate
such an Oracle
given just a poly logarithmic number of
calls to the conditional the conditional
are just if there's a picture so i'll
just show you the picture and then close
this is not really the picture this is
just you know a notion of what does it
mean to have this approximate eval
simulator you give it the point it calls
cond a couple of times in it you know if
it's the point is in the bad said it
either gives up or it gives you an
estimate if the point is not in the bad
set it gives you an estimate the picture
of how the algorithm works is something
like this kind of not too surprising
binary flowcharts so you've got the
original the entire domain you're
interested in the amount of mass that
this point I has well you can just make
some samples from the domain just call
the original article if I is heavy
you'll see it you'll be able to estimate
how much mass it has so that's great if
I is not heavy what should you do you
should put the heavy elements to one
side if there are any you can partition
the domain into two random subsets I
will be in one of those subsets we're
going to have I following the red arrow
so I is in the set s1 and now
intuitively you've had the amount of
weight you have the number of elements
in the subset so you're sort of zooming
in with magnification too and you repeat
the process right make some draws from
the distribution conditioned on this
sample did you get I a bunch of times if
you day if you got I you know then you
can estimate the way to buy relative to
this if not throw away the heavy
elements in this set partition randomly
into few sub pieces so on and so forth
so you have a logarithmic number of
steps you get high-quality estimates of
the ratio of you know this set to this
set this set to this at so on and so
forth it's very much like these
approaches in approximate counting you
multiply together the estimates at the
end once you've reached I in total and
you have a high quality estimate overall
ok I think I should wrap up so just to
briefly state some of the applications
we have for this problem of
distinguishing whether telling whether
to distributions where you have you know
conditional sample access to both
distributions you're interested in
telling whether they're the same or
whether they're far from each other we
have two different algorithms for
solving this problem one of them builds
off of the estimate neighborhood
procedure this first tool that I
mentioned the other one builds off of
this approximate eval procedure and both
these approaches have you know Polly
logarithmic query complexity to the
different kinds of Oracle's and it turns
out and follow-up work jayadev Clemmie
then G have figured out that in fact you
you know it may be possible to improve
on poly log n but it's not going to be
possible to get constant query
complexity for this problem you actually
need some dependence on n to solve this
problem so I think that's it it's a new
model it gives you a lot more efficient
algorithms if you want to run algorithms
in this model and you can imagine a lot
of extensions which hopefully some of
you will think about thank you what's
your new sample you need to the number
of samples see you the relations
happening to me to select the subset so
if you add the total number would you
get back your race number of capsules or
your ask I don't think so I don't think
there's a reason to think that rejection
sample like if you if you sort you're
saying if you naively simulate these con
cui ruiz for your rejection sampling i
don't think in general that'll be as
efficient as approaches yeah yeah I mean
yeah I mean if I'm comparing pairs of
points so I'm going to need if it is
uniform in order to you know actually be
in a situation where I've gotten this
point in this point you'll make linearly
many samples yeah use you promised the
beginning that you're going to talk
about some real application so besides I
don't know my god you're not yeah in CS
theory this passes for an application oh
this is yeah this is the application of
the 20 you know so claremont hasn't it
yeah claremont has an interest in i
guess they're quick there could be
klamath has an interest in you know
talking database people and trying to
convince them that you know got some big
data set you want to build this
functionality into a database for
accessing this said I let him have those
conversations yeah no no I'm just
curious I didn't
so these are the application but it
makes sense we have a variant in which
we charge for you charge more for
conditional sample yeah we thought about
this we had some harebrained ideas about
sort of charging charging according to
the complexity of the of the query so we
thought about okay you know I can
specify a pair Khan query it's two
points to log n I can specify an
interval with to log an and arbitrary
query to an arbitrary subset maybe
should be extremely expensive so you
could you could try to sort of yet
devised a reasonable cost measure and
try to have algorithms which which are
efficient with respect to that cost but
maybe it's more of a qualitative thing
like you know either you believe in the
ability to perform these queries or you
don't and so either might be
perspectives from which the cost is
either infinite for this you know for
one of these queries or it's yeah but
you could think you could think about
things like that yeah thank you